that was a tree at some point
we've lost him well it's because he's a
laid-back botanist he's not doing is
just true he's letting this tree fall
apart do your job my dude hey everyone
what's up welcome back to potato mode
the show where we take the
greatest-looking games out there we turn
the graphics into complete and utter
mush I'm Joey
I'm joined by Ben it's me Ben again
third week in a row I think that's a
record it's got to keep it going I guess
I'll just keep finding find cool games
to play and speaking of cool games we
got some monster hunter world today a
game that was requested quite a bit in
the comments yeah yeah people seem to be
very very excited to see this game get
torn apart there's a lot going on in
this video there's a lot going on giant
monsters little details like the rocks
sprain everywhere flashes of fire
particle effects I broke his tail Hale
how I guess it was you're the monster
yes the whole point of this game look I
need new pants and this engine has got
the parts to make these pants don't come
up here don't don't do this oh my god
damn it Toby
oh there's monsters roaring in my ears
good yeah holy get out of here
why is Rathalos here this would have
been fine is this normal
is this normal I think this is fairly I
don't know anymore well I think we've
seen enough of this game looking good oh
is it time I think it's time well we'll
go one we'll go one step at a time
all right so here are all the graphical
settings that we have in game and
there's they're quite extensive they
have things like resolution scaling LOD
bias anti-aliasing and then in addition
to that there is a lot more stuff that
whoo that Z Pripet is a lot of things
going on here so I'm gonna just go the
complete opposite direction that still
looks all right except for that one
plant that lost all of its oh yeah that
one right there
all of this one two looking looking kind
of rough
I don't do we want to mess with the the
resolution though yes I'm gonna defer to
you this is all I you I've already
answered that question
oh no we're going all the way down forty
by four eight that's my favorite number
oh we could read the FPS though I get
that sixty mark we where's everything
else do you think Oh turn that off no
limit no Larry hundred FPS Joey that's
so many frames we've broken the record I
can't hold all these frames
okay maybe them 90 or so 95 is not too
shabby
unfortunately this graphic say I'd set
the language to Japanese and I kind of
regret it because I can't read it now
honey up there is Oh
swing-and-a-miss the effects are still
there there's still kind of they're a
little blurry
it looks playable - the not being able
to read anything on the on the screen
when you don't want to be bothered by
exposition or narrative now the
resolution like I can't tell that the
resin or the textures are too bad that
because of the the resolution I think
unless I like look at it yeah is that
well if that's the case we can uh take
care of the textures making it make it
even worse I think let's do that alright
I'm in at this point in the show I don't
know if we even need to explain what
goes on here or walk people through it
step by step you've seen it in video
profile inspector we're gonna remove all
the textures lead everything oh no
everything is so smooth we've lost I
think what we have lost
we've lost the end we've lost we've lost
the sky you've lost the sky except for a
really like low resolution moon go keep
keep going up oh we can see seeing some
oh there's a circle though because
that's the that's the edge that's the
origin point Oh No if you've seen the
the crisis episode of potato mode you
know that everything's a simulation
anyway it's real nothing's real
we can we can get some food well we'll
go check out we'll check out the cat's
see how they're doing
spoiler alert they're not gonna be very
good probably not good
let's go for the the top one usually oh
oh I I almost want to say it's not too
bad yeah big pot of white gunk I'm kind
of yeah I'm kind of there's something
kinda like I'm kind of into it a little
bit I think you've been on too many
episodes I bet I've seen too much potato
and I'm pretty sure that's the problem
like once you like oh maybe this is like
a like an artsy kind of thing you know
me yes and you see this that's kind of
the reason why I have guests on because
if it was just me I would just be like
oh just potato again I guess you know
what let's just go on an adventure and
let let the game tell us we're gonna
fight let the wind take us wherever we
want I want to check out the coral
Highlands one of the most beautiful
areas in the game okay
shapes they're just shapes
low-resolution coral is is a real treat
so the whole point of this zone is that
it's supposed to look like it's
underwater without being underwater nice
little Wiggly they look like french
fries yeah right fries french fries
hanging out here on the top of this this
shelf then we got all of this to look
out at some some cool man lit up areas
over there Scott of pinks and Red's
going on I like this area yeah this is
nice
I mean it's nice as a campy well I think
nice takes on a very different meaning
it's true on potato mode I feel
conflicted with how much I'm like
enjoying this it's it's hey Joey is this
a good potato ma I don't know Joey if
we've we broken the the the course of
everything what is happening the
universe is inverting on itself yeah
it's gonna get to a point where we start
doing it in Reverse we start off on this
and be like whoa let's hope we make it
look better
Oh No there's our big old puffy rat boy
I need to pick it I picked something up
I can't recognize the plants oh the the
particle effects they're squares now
officially I think I got a little a
little preview of that yeah look at that
squares you got squares confirmed oh my
god what that's what I was hoping for so
this guy he puffs up it looks just about
as gross as I thought it would
oh it's disgusting no like the fur on
this thing's likes to yeah you can see
the strips it's not the official term
they'll be the hair strips the hair
strips we're talking about hair strips
before in yahooza your faded I got too
caught up and I'm looking at everything
and now Here I am
garbage dumped on the ground got carted
away yeah we can go out one more time I
think before we do that though we can
take a look at one more thing that I
forgot to mention is that we also have
in addition to a potato potato fiying
the game we have a little bit of fun
with we are going to have a little bit
of fun with the reciate err option whoo
and so if you haven't seen reciate err
it's basically an external program that
allows you to put filters on like color
you can increase contrast you can do a
whole ton of things with it
holy crap it's very big so we have
things right here you can see oh this
one adds colorfulness border around the
screen yeah I had more bloom whoa make
it look like a CRT just like a CRT just
like I remember it can add a sepia tone
to it oh my goodness happy holidays Joey
I don't know if I could play like this
oh my goodness how'd you even know that
was there
this this is some memory still from from
all these hours that I've played which
is probably helping me out a bit is that
is that him up here yeah it is
let's go like that that is that blood or
is it like the sparks or whatever
particle effect that's coming out is
actually pretty cool so the I know this
guy has oh god okay all right
this is fine just joking all the health
puppies won't let me drink if I max
health so I think I'm good oh my little
little buddies trying to help
what is know let's keep it in the stall
Jack I don't like this okay
all right I can kind of kind of see
what's going on I wonder what this is
supposed to be what am i what am i
nostalgic for what's up dude I told you
yeah oh he's still drooling it's not in
a good place still these filters are
Connor
yeah you like he's real puffy again no
it's not anymore and I just jump on yeah
I'm kind of down with I wouldn't I
wouldn't play like this intentionally
oh no I hit one of those sleepy toads
and now we're that's gonna take a nap
really quick you're just getting the
middle like a really intense fight you
accidentally hit the the sleeping
sleeping stuff and yeah just a little
bit back to work
don't you dare fly away he's all puffy
though you can't I can't believe it I
don't have the buffs I can't see my
health I say we go we go one more do we
want to change the filter up against go
one let's do one more so let's get rid
of nostalgia for Mike aberration give it
a little blur okay cartoon Oh I've said
that master haunted make it good like
Saturday morning again ASCII I don't
know if I need that I didn't ask you for
this at all we get can we bring it in
oh man I think I think I might be as
good as we can do it's me I'm cured to
do a monster fight right so this should
be doing like how every time we go past
that it it just looks it looks
completely different every time I've
come for you don't drop on me I just I
swear
save me save me palico Oh couldn't do it
I'm gonna make an honest run at this I
said one more time like five times but
what's Oh God that was frightening I
couldn't stand to look at it got right
out of there let me just see a whole
other part of the map that we haven't
looked at yet oh wow got got all sorts
of trees everywhere a lot of pink a lot
of pink but do this do that get in here
a couple of these couple of those and
he's done just gonna grab grab these
parts you ready to make another pair of
pants well I think that was a very
successful hunt bin it was a very good
hunt I think that went as just about as
well as we could have ever imagined
thank you guys so much for watching once
again if you have a game and might I add
a PC game that you'd like to see potato
fide make sure to leave it in the
comments below and just remember if you
like watching the show make sure to
check out one of our
shows grave hoppers which is live on
Thursdays 2 p.m. Pacific where you can
find Rob Henry and Michael Hardy playing
through all sorts of games with only one
life oh hey look at this we have a cool
trailer for it right here
welcome to grave hoppers the show where
we put permadeath into every game you
die in a game you move on to the next oh
my god dude you had no help join us live
every Thursday 2:00 p.m. Pacific don't
miss it
what hit me no anyways thank you guys so
much for watching and we will see you
all next Friday I'll potato move
beautiful recurring the ceiling we got
there it's really important to have a
flickering ceiling to remind yourself of
the beauty of the sunset life is like a
potato and that you there are so many
ways that you couldn't cook it some
people go through the work their life
fry other people go through it raw or
fake or slice or or scalloped or just
wit by with their skin so they just fill
up their skins with cheese